oh my god of course we're talking beauty
stuff right here we're back with double
trouble Nikki and Brie Bella yeah
Beauty yummy okay this Valentine's Day
season if you're a Taylor Swift fan in
the Chicago area who recently survived a
breakup well guess what there's a bar
just for you CNN reports that bad blood
is a breakup bar with a Taylor Swift
theme it's a pop-up it's only open until
February 26th and it offers a full
soundtrack of all of Taylor's hits about
how we are never ever ever ever getting
back together there's even a shake it
off wheel of cocktails and Taylor's
songs listen they have helped people you
know through emotional times I just
think you know she's really connected
with so many people she has a rabid fan
base and I think this pop-up bar is a
great idea and if it does well who knows
maybe they'll stay open all year long
yeah I think a Taylor Swift bar is a
great idea because I have gone in a bar
looked at a bottle of tequila and
thought I knew you were trouble when I
walked in I knew but it's fun you know I
would totally go do you guys like theme
bars
and I think when you go go through a
breakup how perfect to go in and like
take your anger out on like a great
cocktail menu well and then you'd be
like surrounded by everyone who's kind
of going through the same thing yeah so
then it's like you know Kumbaya moments
yeah on your Blues together all right up
next Instagram they've announced a new
feature I want your your take on you
guys got like a combined what is it 19
million followers come by 19 million
yeah wow
so you're IG experts see if you would
like this Mashable reports you can now
set your Instagram account to something
called quiet mode so it's like you'll
find this in your notification settings
and it's basically a do not disturb
function like your texts have that
silences all notifications you can turn
it on or off you can set a specific
schedule if you want and they hope it'll
help teens focus on their homework or
help the rest of us avoid that Doom
scrolling in bed for hours wherever you
do it and it's suddenly three in the
morning and you're like a little oops I
love that I love that I actually think
it's really smart and I I think not only
for myself because I can totally fall
into that Doom scrolling but I think for
kids I think it's consuming everyone and
it takes away from your brain just like
having free moments and being clear so I
think yes quiet mode thank you
well there's always a good and a
challenging side to everything it's the
polarity and I do love a good Tick Tock
I think I think it's a really fun
enjoyable platform and they have so many
different informative things and a
beauty trend is you know all the rage so
we had to try this one ourselves this
one feels personal to me because
actually this is something my dad used
his whole life
um now it's olive oil ladies and
gentlemen
um so the guardian reports we are just
in time for chapped lip season I feel
like it's been here for a few months but
I'm 48 so that's why so there is a lip
balm alternative out there it's been on
your kitchen counter staring at you
right in your dry little face for ages
it's olive oil so after you cook with it
you can also dip your little fingers in
there and you can just dab it on your
lips like I'm an Italian restaurant my
dad was a human salad he just uh lemons
to as an astringent there were lemons
just everywhere and bottles of olive oil
to moisturize really wow I love that do
you remember that scene in Under the
Tuscan Sun when the hot guy sticks down
to Diane Lane and dips his finger in
olive oil and then does that thing with
it and like he like like gives her a
look like that anyway I remember
thinking that was the hottest thing I've
ever seen I don't quite pulling it off
oh my God
we had little uh little thingies that's
a doe foot that's what this is called oh
that's cute and the beauty biz that's
what we call a doe foot that's adorable
you know what else we call in the beauty
biz uh Nikki and Brie because you're so
beautiful
[Applause]
no wonder you have so many people
following you I want to hang on your
every word and whim I just love you guys
so much and may we always do this show
together please
[Applause]
actress Megan Good is here we'll be
right back
thank you
[Music]